un candidat à la présidence américaine
qui accompagnent des américains venus
acheter leurs médicaments au canada
voilà qui n'est pas chose commune à ce
même candidat le sénateur du vermont
bernie sanders se sert de toutes les
tribunes pour faire l'apologie du
système de santé canadien
et voilà maintenant que l'administration
tranche veut mettre en place un système
qui permettra aux américains d'importer
légalement des médicaments d'ordonnancé
moins chers du canada on fm de mêler le
canada dans un débat politico économique
qui ne nous concerne pas vraiment c'est
vraiment une fausse solution
sur le fond ça ne veut pas régler la
question des prix qui sont extrêmement
élevée aux etats unis c'est plus de
théâtre que d'autres choses
c'est pas parce que monsieur propre et
le gouvernement américain permet
d'importer des médicaments à partir du
canada que le canada va permettre d'en
exporter aux états unis la proposition
prévoit que les patients américains
pourrait importer des médicaments sous
la surveillance de la food and drug
administration
mais les modalités sont floues et la
mise en oeuvre nécessitera au moins un
an selon cet analyste ans il semble que
il sait on veut pas vraiment que ça
fonctionne on va faire une proposition
qui très peu praticable pour le canada
et qui risque de créer énormément de
résistance de la part du gouvernement
canadien
ensuite on va simplement blâmer le
gouvernement canadien si ça va on ne
risque pas aller de l'avant
les pharmaciens sont en état d' alerte
déjà on a beaucoup de pénurie
médicaments canada des pharmaciens sont
devenus des experts en milieu
hospitalier communautaire pour gérer ces
pénuries là où on voudrait pas d'en
avoir plus haut c'est certain les
pharmaciens demandent aux autorités
canadiennes de faire preuve de vigilance
alors voilà c'est les américains régler
le problème entre eux et nous on va
consulter bien servir nos patients ici
au québec et au canada par voie de
communiqué la ministre fédérale de la
santé soutient que l'une de ses
priorités est de s'assurer que tous les
canadiens est accès aux médicaments dont
ils ont besoin elle entend engager une
ce qu sion avec les américains au sujet
de leur intention ici maxime bertrand
radio canada montréal